I was very surprised somewhat very tired
because I got to sleep one hour before
so I was just getting into sleep and I
think initially the feeling of shock
disbelief but then the committee was
very clever they ask you questions that
only they wouldn't know it so people
said to me you had to send that review
40 years ago and you never did it where
is it and somebody else said remember
how we got drunk in Italy in the
summertime and each person other person
said when you go to the archipelago you
better come with me don't go by yourself
so this made me realize and actually
talked to the chairman of the committee
today and he said that somebody last
year had been called the night before on
a joke or and when they called him he
was really upset so they decided from
now on they would have this verification
scheme very quickly you it's a real
shock I was like I described it as five
double expresso maybe it was seven but
it was really as an adrenaline burst
that's amazing have a nice drug